e aí
e recentemente eu tava voltando de uma
das minhas viagens frequência trabalho e
passei por uma situação inesperada era
um voo com conexão entre duas companhias
aéreas diferentes e quando eu sair do
primeiro voo eu percebi que eu tinha
esquecido de fazer o check in do segundo
peguei o celular rapidamente para fazer
mas aparece uma mensagem de check-in
online encerrado já deu aquele frio na
barriga era uma sexta-feira final do dia
calculei que não daria tempo de sair da
área de embarque e até o guichê de
check-in depois voltar tudo passar pelo
raio-x e decidiu tentar a sorte direto
lá no portão de embarque cheguei lá pedi
para o funcionário da companhia aérea
fazer para mim ele concordou e e digitou
digitou e me disse que o check-in tava
mesmo encerrado e eu pedi para ele
tentar ligar para alguém para ver se eu
nem consegui a reabrir o check-in mas
ele disse que às vezes eles conseguem e
aí ele disse que não dava porque já
tinha fechada mais do que cinco minutos
oi e aí eu apelei falei eu preciso
voltar para casa hoje eu tenho filha
pequena quero dormir em casa e ele falou
senhor não dá para fazer e aí eu envie
no impasse uma situação que acontece
quando as pessoas tem posições
conflitantes e interesses aparentemente
inconciliáveis e já assumindo que eu
realmente perderia o voo que eu não
voltaria para casa nesse dia eu parei
para pensar que eu não precisava
convencê-lo a fazer o check-in para mim
eu precisava que ele me colocasse dentro
do voo e resolvi tentar de outra forma
eu voltei nele falei as pessoas que
ficam aqui nessa lista de espera para
tentar entrar no voo elas não fizeram
ser quem porque elas não são do voo como
você consegue colocar leite para dentro
ele falar eu lanço manualmente tá então
se eu tivesse na lista de espera você
conseguiria me colocar dentro do voo ele
falou se tivesse vaga sim eu disse bom
vaga vai ter né porque eu tô no volume
não fiz o cheque então certa verde
é uma asinha vai ter tão falei eu vou
ficar aqui esperando na hora que você
chamasse não aparecer ninguém que seja
prioridade eu vou deu certo eu peguei um
voo e dormir em casa os impasses dos
mais simples como esse até os mais
complexos estão presentes no nosso
dia-a-dia e é muito difícil prever
quando eles vão aparecer você sai de
casa querendo ter um dia tranquilo mas
aí descobre que seu filho se envolveu no
problema na escola que alguém roubou sua
ideia no trabalho o vizinho bate na sua
porta para fazer uma reclamação e quando
você vê você está no meio de um impasse
ea forma como nós lidamos com esses
impasses é determinante para a qualidade
dos nossos relacionamentos e para
alcançar os nossos objetivos e como os
impasses são imprevisíveis é muito
importante saber lidar com eles então
hoje eu vou falar sobre duas formas de
lidar com impasses que eu já fazia
intuitivamente e quanto mais eu fui
estudando e dando aulas sobre gestão de
a negociação mas eu fui reforçando a
visão de que elas são ferramentas
poderosíssimos a primeira é descobrir o
real problema a ser resolvido nos
impasses mas entramos muito fechados na
nossa demanda inicial e discussão acaba
ficando amarrada no ponto que muitas
vezes não é o real problema para
descobrir qual é a real questão é
preciso dar um passo atrás se distanciar
um pouco dessa discussão simplista do
tipo posso não posso' quero não quero
para então mergulhar e tentar entender
de forma mais profunda o que está por
trás dela isso pode ser feito através de
perguntas do tipo porque precisa ser
assim porque isso é tão importante para
você porque não poderíamos resolver de
tal forma e se tentássemos seguir por
esse caminho a resposta para essas
perguntas pode re fornecer informações
e eu disse mas para você entender qual é
de fato o problema que pode nem ser uma
questão objetiva mas sim uma necessidade
humana do tipo se sentir respeitado ser
ouvido receber um pedido de desculpas
pelo seu status reconhecido pelo seu
poder de escolha ter autonomia a segunda
é buscar soluções criativas o ser humano
é muito criativo mas quando ele defende
certamente as suas convicções rígidas o
cérebro entra no modo de batalha e essa
criatividade de sucesso no caso do voo a
solução era simples e até óbvia mas ela
só apareceu quando eu parei de tentar
impor a minha solução e me abrir para
caminhos que eu não tinha esperado para
resolver o meu problema e com isso ele
também parou de se defender então vamos
ver o uso dessas duas ferramentas em
outra situação
é uma mão na minha muito dedicada
conciliava o trabalho com os estudos e
quando ela foi fazer as inscrições no
último período da faculdade ela percebeu
que duas das matérias que ela precisava
fazer para se formar só estavam
disponíveis no período da tarde não
seria inconciliável com seu trabalho já
que o gestor parecia ser rígido com o
pontualidade e diante desse conflito de
horários e imcompatibilidade do trabalho
com os estudos ela refletiu bastante e
concluiu que no momento ela precisava
focar em se formar e decidiu pedir
demissão esses podem estar se
perguntando é porque ela já partiu para
essa decisão simplista né e extrema de
pedir demissão sem ao menos tentar
conversar com seu chefe para resolver o
problema é que como a maioria das
pessoas que se deparam com impasses ela
desde considerou o que ele poderia de
alguma forma contribuir para solução por
achar que o
um deles eram completamente opostos como
se eles fossem adversários o chefe ficou
muito surpreso com esse pedido de
demissão e começou a querer entender é
porque esse ano seria diferente dos
outros em que ela conseguiu conciliar e
ela só dizia que já tava na hora de
informar que não podia perder mais tempo
precisava concluir a faculdade e com
isso ele foi com essas respostas ele foi
tendo a sensibilidade para perceber que
o problema ali não era ela tem que
escolher entre trabalhar ou estudar o
problema era como ela poderia executar o
trabalho dela nos próximos seis meses
sem poder estar na empresa duas tardes
por semana quando isso ficou claro novas
possibilidades que se abriram e eles
começaram a discutir possibilidades com
amor ela é definir o escopo de trabalho
dela tirando algumas funções que eram
meramente operacionais renegociar os
prazos de alguns projetos
me perguntam prioritário concluíram até
que um dos dias que ela tinha aula à
tarde era melhor ela nem aí para empresa
de manhã trabalhar de casa e de lá e
direto para a universidade já que esse
tempo de deslocamento seria melhor
aproveitar não foi fácil assim mas com
muito esforço eles conseguiram chegar a
uma solução ela continua na empresa se
formou ea relação entre eles ficou ainda
mais sólida nesse caso ela até se
beneficiou da curiosidade e
sensibilidade do gestor para tentar
entender o problema e resolver o que ela
poderia ter feito de qualquer forma não
dá sorte de ter um bom gestor assim
seria antes de tomar aquela decisão
parar para refletir um pouco mais sobre
qual era a questão e quando ela tivesse
clareza sobre isso poderia ter
compartilhado o problema com ele já que
e convidado por uma solução conjunta já
que quando as pessoas se sentem parte
elas têm a tendência muito maior estar
dispostos a tentar
e esse quebra-cabeça a cumprir esse
desafio e recentemente eu me envolvi num
outro em paz e esse ainda nem está
completamente resolvido eu comprei um
carro usado e pouco tempo depois ele tem
um problema sério no motor eu levei numa
concessionária autorizada e eles
forçaram um concerto em 28.000 reais
e eu ainda não estava assustado porque o
carro estava na garantia e quando eu fui
escrever o e-mail para a loja onde eu
comprei eu descobri que a garantia de 90
dias tinha terminado há dois dias o
motor deu pane 92 dias depois da minha
compra e é verdade é
e ainda assim eu não estava tão
preocupado porque eu acreditava que o
motor já tinha vindo com esse problema
que era um vídeo seu culto mas a
resposta da loja foi simples e direta
sua garantia terminou não temos
responsabilidade
e jamais preocupado eu liguei para o
dono da loja para tentar conversar sobre
a questão e ele batendo de que não dava
para ficar com conserto não tinha como
se responsabilizar e o tentando
convencê-lo do contrário impasse nem eu
parei para pensar e essa altura você já
deve até imaginar pergunta que eu me fiz
na qual é meu problema aqui eu não
preciso convencê-lo a me pagar 28.000
riacho eu preciso ter um carro
funcionando e aí passei a tentar
estabelecer um diálogo produtivo eu
perguntei para ele você acha que o
orçamento da concessionária tá caro ele
falou acho tão absurdo tá e se fosse um
dos seus carros como você resolveria o
problema ele falar eu levaria um dos
nossos mecânico de confiança ele
certamente consertaria isso por r$5000
um pouco mais do que isso eu disse bom
tá claro para mim que nós temos visões
bem diferentes
e eu acho que eu tenho direito você acha
que eu não tenho se nós formos levar
esse caso para a justiça nós vamos
perder tempo dinheiro pode ser que a
decisão seja favorável mim pode ser que
seja para você não dá para ter certeza a
única coisa que é certa que a solução
vai ser muito ruim para um dos dois
então vamos tentar investir um tempo
aqui para ver se não haveria alguma
solução que fosse boa para ambos e que
dependesse só da gente e começamos a
pensar bom se a gente tirar o carro lá
na concessionária a gente vai ter que
pagar pelo orçamento já que você não
consertar lá eles cobram e vamos ter que
pagar pelo reboque para levar até o
outro mecânico um paga o orçamento o
outro paga o rebote ok o mecânico de
confiança ou sou o conserto em 7 mil
reais com prazo de entrega de 60 dias ok
7000 é bem melhor do que os 28 mas quem
paga o 7 mil novo impasse e
nós estamos a tentar compor alguma
solução e chegamos à conclusão de que
nós dividiremos o curso do conserto com
a condição de que eles entregaram o
carro na minha casa já que o mecânico
ficava numa outra cidade com o prazo de
garantia para este serviço maior e que
durante o tempo de concerto que poderia
dizer 60 dias ou mais eles me emprestar
iam um carro reserva para usar o carro
da tá lá sendo consertado então vamos
ver se vai dar certo até o final mas o
ponto aqui é mostrar aqui mesmo nas
situações mais adversariais é possível
encontrar soluções inteligentes no caso
desse carro reserva daí essas soluções
inteligentes passam por tentar encontrar
trocas que tenham baixo custo para um e
alto benefício para o outro então nesse
caso do carro reserva para ele
simplesmente tirar um dos 50 carros que
ficam parados no
e ele tem um custo muito baixo para mim
isso já é um benefício muito grande já
que se eu fosse alugar um carro desse
nível por esse período isso poderia me
custar até mais do que o conserto e aí
que tá a magia da criação de valor pode
fazer com que as partes saiam até mais
satisfeitos do que imaginavam e com
algum relacionamento preservado
é o que todas as histórias têm em comum
é que existem diversas formas de
resolver um problema se você acha que a
melhor delas e simplesmente tentar impor
o seu ponto de vista de forma agressiva
e rígida e o proponho a seguinte
reflexão todo impasse é um morre
e se cada um simplesmente puxa para o
seu lado e se não vai ficando cada vez
mais apertado mas se vocês tentam
entender como esse nó está amarrado e
vão fazendo movimentos sincronizados
esse novas soltando até que ele se
dissolve completamente nas suas mãos
quando o impasse cruzar o seu caminho
tudo que eu peço é para que você pare e
pense entender qual é o real problema
que você pode não estar enxergando a
primeira vista e busque soluções
criativas para resolver mas busque beijo
não deixe de tentar criar por achar que
ele não vai ouvir ele não vai aceitar o
que não adianta nem tentar se você
tentar estabelecer um diálogo produtivo
que passa por ouvir genuinamente fazer
perguntas inteligente e adotar uma
postura
e funcionalmente construtiva você vai
alcançar muitas coisas que aparentemente
seriam aprovadas muito obrigada
e aí